from Gaining 16 million followers on
Tick Tock every single Tick Tock comment
is requesting me to do more red flag
proud work to shutting down Ticketmaster
server while selling out his world tour
this kid sold out a world tour in a day
shut down Ticketmaster at the age of 27
Matt Rife has already made some serious
waves in the comedy world and has plenty
of people talking you got that guy you
have Matt Rife Matt Wright Matt Rice
this
is comedians on Matt Rife he's suspect
to me Matt Rife is somebody I look at
him and I go oh I could beat him up
but he's a boxer though it doesn't
matter I feel like I can so he wouldn't
be but you I just know you would defeat
me right in a real you would never
because your insides would go against my
point though because you're a good guy
but I'm just saying if we didn't know
each other yeah and I went in and I you
know you know hugely boogly your kids
you know what I mean yeah you're saying
I could get it to a level what does
googly moogly mean who knows who knows
because I think yeah because I think you
know what the difference is because I
think I know a little bit more about
history than that right so my hate for
Asians is more than him because when you
look at history you really want to hate
the Asians can we talk about that real
quick yeah as you got more successful
has the bitterness worn off 100 really
yeah everybody gives uh I don't want to
say his name because everybody mentioned
it but like the hot guy with the shirt
off everybody's talking about him can
you believe this guy and there's all
these Pages dedicated to hating him and
I'm like I don't care let him do his
thing he's killing it yeah what do I
give a [__] but if you were 20 starting
comedy do you feel like you would have
probably yeah yeah yeah and I know a lot
of big Comics now who used to have
podcasts solely to [__] on other
Comedians and now they're huge and they
don't do that yeah it's all insecurity
and no one wants no one internalizes no
one goes maybe I suck most dudes that
look like that are not that funny yeah
and most of these look like that are
women
right I know look I love my commit it's
awesome it's awesome to see anybody
doing well but nobody has that I mean
Matt it looks better than a lot of the
women that I've dated I think honestly
he's beautiful the God is damn beautiful
yeah he is beautiful I mean I a thousand
percent agree that he is and blacks like
him yeah
All Blacks a lot of them yeah Shemar
Moore got on stage with him the other
day yeah I think I saw that I saw that
yeah that was insane yeah
um and and I saw that yeah because he
goes you know I'm I'm pretty too like he
was like standing up for pretty men yeah
it was the wildest [__] where he's like
we're people too all right and we
deserve yeah yeah yeah it was wild yeah
we need a few more mirrors in the
economy
it was insane me and you were both not
the handsomest guys we have flaws yeah
but if you [__] maximize it dude
so do you dude I know we're two guys who
have a lot in common we're guys who are
not traditionally handsome but we
[__] maximize I got the glasses to
separate the eyes you got the rip nice
rims to distract from tanks
I mean I can't speak for myself but I I
never saw you as I always saw you as a
pretty good looking kid I saw you as a
good looking guy too but I'm also I'm
aware we're not we're not Matt Rife
types no but who is besides Matt Rife
you know what I mean that's like saying
like I'm not you know he's a great
looking kid it's like six saying I'm not
a Brad Pitt we're ordinary looking guys
with flaws yeah yeah I I feel like you
could get in shape as much as possible
and you'd still have a double chin
really the two Comics left in La it's
like the same guy and the two people
that are fighting for dominance of the
LA comedy scene right now are literally
indistinguishable from each other which
is weird and it's me and Matt Rife
it's the same guy and we're we're
talking about the same things and so
what it really is is this fight between
these two brothers who are the same yes
to try to try to reach these people
Jesus Christ is this what Matt looks
like
that's what I look like too it's these
cameras you don't have nice cameras
that's the problem is these [__]
cameras
Rogan invested all the money in deer
antlers and not the cameras because
without the camera no but we're very
similar we look alike we're the same
type of guy and it's weird it's weird
and it's just both of us in L.A like
fighting for like who's gonna do it
that's the photo is that a lion
that's the photo that where it's like so
it's hard to that's what La is right now
it's just me and this guy yeah fighting
for Supremacy yeah
being the same you know what I mean sure
my crowd is all women because they're
brilliant yeah
because they're very smart they're
indicator
the to the takes I did a show at me
Shane Mullen and Big Jay who was in
Arena always all women yeah all women
came out in Hershey Pennsylvania all
women who voted for Joseph mine that's
my audience women who voted for Joseph
Biden do you and Matt get along or is it
pretty contentious no it's we we get
along because it's like
but it's contentious because it's always
tough to see your doppelganger
all the time and it's like it's like
it's like no Matt's actually an awesome
dude it's like a really sweet guy and
he's funny and awesome but
um and we do look different you do
so that's that's that's good I think
that's good it is so cute he's very he's
very attractive from a from a movie or
is that like a Cake Boss but I dated her
and let me tell you something and that
came back and chill you go to dinner
with her I mean you gotta fill the
conversation
laughs
[Laughter]
I can't wait to tell you guys this this
is the one that hurt the most
this one hurt I don't know what story
this is so you're not getting this and
protect your Park this won't hurt so
[__] much so I did the Blue Room in
Springfield Missouri great room ticket
sales dog [__] I got those Springfield
numbers and it bummed me out for an
afternoon where like Katie had to rub my
back at one point because I was going
like this I mean 40 years ago 40 tickets
a show since 250. and she's just going
like hey it's Springfield it's the third
Market in Missouri and I'm like I know I
just [__] so we go I know ticket
sales are low
fly to Kansas City drive down to
Springfield I get to Springfield I get
to my hotel I go upstairs and there's
like 11 texts from random Comics not
like you guys are my you know like
Comics that I'm friends with but I don't
really talk to and they all screen
grabbed the same promo oh no free
tickets dogs worse dude you get it on
wrong don't you take Grandma's this
weekend this is about to ruin every
story you've ever told because Joe knows
this the story I sent this to Joan joint
oh god um please
show it to Louis
hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna show it to
both of you and then explain just read
it don't write just just read what it is
no excited
I'm sweating
The Comedy Club put on Instagram it
wrote Matt Rife fans get a chance to see
dance soda a chance and Matt Wright
anyone who buys a ticket to see Dan
Soder this weekend will be issued a
raffle ticket
each person in attendance to a show will
be entered in a chance to win so it was
a raffle ticket it wasn't even another
ticket it was a raffle ticket and dude I
saw that and it was such a gut pundy
that I was like oh that hurts I mean you
get better off just going and getting
homeless people and putting dude that
was in the solar plex I was like I've
used that word twice this podcast thanks
Bobby I mean the idea of like the crowd
being filled with people that are just
there
ABC Matt Ryan and every show I made sure
when a joke would hit I'd go God I hope
you guys win Matt Rife tickets and you
would hear them laugh an acknowledgment
laughs
good looking affording them dude I'll
figure it out dude
you don't have to have the tickets in
there yeah honestly you didn't win and
honestly like good for that guy that
he's doing so well that it's a [__]
raffle ticket I like Matt Rife I do
never met him but no he's doing so well
this guy nice guy like Rogan is jacked
right yeah but that's almost an anomaly
but he he does his best to mask that uh
on stage on a stage he wears oversized
[__] all the time
because what happens is if if he were
wearing like fitted like a fitted shirt
then you'd be like look at this guy's
[__] jacked body right you're
watching and then muscles you just just
you'd be watching yeah and you want
people to like not be distracted by it
yeah that's true if a woman's wearing
like really fitted out you're like okay
and that's what you're gonna look at you
know you see like most women like will
wear if they're really doing stand up
and taking it serious like most of them
won't
yeah yeah I think it's kind of a thing
you have to do unless you're Matt Rife
yeah then you're a beautiful woman and
you can show it yeah I mean in any orbit
he's going to do well now it's like
that's what the new thing is yeah you
know he could do a gender reveal on
himself once a year and people would
[__] lose their minds
I think you have to dream big but don't
say yes to things you're not ready for
sometimes you have to what are you gonna
turn down matt Rife for example people
are like he hasn't been doing comedy
enough to like do all these things do
your research yeah but he what's he
supposed to turn down a world tour would
you turn it down people who are judging
him I know good question so it's like
shut up people are offering him these
things let him do it and he also uh not
that most people seem to be like in
favor of met Rife because he's such a
nice person yeah and I as someone who is
also known as a nice person I know when
I get successful people go
you deserve it like people go and it's
like because I'm talented because I was
nice to you before like people I think
that people like when nice people get
things more than shitty people yeah this
makes sense yes but it steals some of
your like Talent away when they go you
deserve it because you work hard and you
go
I know but then there are other people
like I think Theo who is so naturally
funny seemingly and it seems like he
doesn't work for it that when he when
yes thank you Theo people tell him God
you're just so naturally funny and I
think people like him I don't mean to
speak for him get mad when people don't
acknowledge how hard he's worked for
totally some people say he's an NPC or
something or he's a what doing something
for Biden or whatever
Jesus Christ is that what Matt looks
like I see this is like the second time
I've seen him yeah I don't even want to
see that much I've never seen honestly
I've never seen that much of any man
yeah I mean here's the thing it's uh I
mean look at this dude he's resting he
just
getting a little rest in on his muscle
no you know what this is a good it's a
good one to bring up because this is
actually
against everything that you're told is
possible
um where somebody's like he's a handsome
like good looking kid I mean he looks
like a model you know he's a model yeah
model body and then he is a funny guy
though I mean he's a funny dude I've
seen him uh I've seen the clips that
they're all guys are funny man and he
really knows like he's fun working a
room really good and yeah I mean he's
just good at that so yeah you can't say
that it's impossible but also it's
Unique though it's very unique it's it's
it's it's
um it's singular it's like it
it works with him doing what he's doing
yeah I don't understand wow and I'm not
saying this to be negative because I
like the kid and I'm happy for him which
means you're going to say something
negative no no it's not negative I just
don't understand how he came out of
nowhere like I've never seen him in New
York usually you'll see somebody and
back and forth in L.A that's old school
ways okay the new school is you just you
can you don't it really was New York or
LA and then that's that sort of
headlining and making real money in
communities
well you see him around headlining I
never really even saw him around
headlining that long yeah he's been
around he's been doing it a while he's
been around like he's starting Columbia
I just found out this he's not in
Columbus he's been doing like 10 years I
think I think more than that even a
little more he started when he was like
because I think the first time I met him
was when I was running a Conan set in
like 2012 and you just have to laugh oh
wow there you go gripe is our boy Connor
right yeah we we're big Mount right fans
he's a friend of the show Friends of the
show Matt right yeah is he genuinely no
I've been dming him a lot though really
has he been answering no no
I I think he gets an unfair amount of
hate yeah probably
I feel like it's a bunch of like um like
a lot of comics that are here talk [__]
about them it just it feels like uh like
metal bands talking [__] about a boy
band yeah yeah it doesn't really make
sense do you want that audience no I
said the same thing someone sent me an
uh an interview with him to be like look
how crazy this uh this quote is and I
read the quote and I was like it's not
that crazy and I kept reading and he was
like he seemed pretty self-aware he's
like yeah my audience is 18 to 25 year
old woman and they shout out because
they want to be on Tick Tock he's like
that kind of sucks and you're like yeah
that really sucks yeah it really sucks
and I think what it is is anytime every
comic's like this anytime dude I I know
comics and I'm not gonna name names but
I know Comics that are very very
successful and the second anyone gets
near them yeah they turn into who they
were back down here yes they're like
still down here where they're like yeah
you think he's [__] good yeah right
he's doing well yeah he's doing well you
guys are doing the same thing yeah it's
fine and I've been through that like
I've [__] [__] on people and stuff
and I'm like dude I don't really really
care it's it's just funny and
interesting to like discuss and break
down yeah but I if you're this is such a
hard business if you're doing well
[__] congratulations man
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out